hey what's up guys my name is trying to
welcome back to my game engine series
it's the last time we talked about
camera controls if we check out that
video if you haven't already
we basically implemented this
orthographic camera controller so that
we could put all the behavior for that
camera controller in a separate class
and basically have it do whatever we
wanted to do based on the input that we
receive from our keyboard and mouse
today we're going to be talking about
what happens when our window resizes
because currently in hazal if we just
take a look if we try and resize this
window that we have here to a different
size it doesn't really work properly you
can see that if I try and make it bigger
for example or I try and maximize it
then we have this kind of cut cut off
region where I like I can still move the
camera but you can see this area here is
not kind of being rendered whatsoever
which is kind of annoying then that's
basically because we're not setting now
properly whatsoever
all we're doing is we're handling a
window resizing the shell of W and that
is kind of resizing the area in a way
but it's not really at all so to handle
this stuff properly we have to ask
ourselves what does a resize actually do
what does it mean and for us
specifically resizing has a number of
different effects essentially first of
all winter that we used to think about
our actual rendering buffer so when we
render everything in OpenGL we render it
to a destination meaning that these
pixels that were kind of outputting from
our fragment shader are not really
outputting from our fragment shader but
you get the point the pixels that were
actually rendering they need to go
somewhere they need to be stored
somewhere in memory the size of that
buffer has to be the size of the
available pixels that we're rendering on
our screen now there's a lot of
different considerations that go into
this for example it's quite common
perhaps to render at like half the
resolution and then scale that final
buffer up and then what happens though
eventually with that is that final
buffer it still has to be the amount of
pixels that we have on our screen so
basically what I'm saying is it's not
just as simple as resizing our window we
need to actually tell if in jail that
the rendering area has changed we do
that using something called GL viewport
what that does is basically just sets
the viewport that we're entering into
this is kind of useful if you're
rendering to multiple viewports as well
for example if you've seen like a 3d
modeling application of like a 3d
rendering kind of program where you have
like all your different viewports being
displayed there might be like a
perspective one and then like you know
left top right or left top the other one
left top front right something like that
that's also an example of kind of
setting viewports where we may want to
rent a different views from different
cameras and then kind of composite that
all into one frame at the end but we're
not trying to do anything complicated
like that all we need to do as far as
you as far as viewports are concerned is
just tell OpenGL that this is my
rendering area it's changed from being
like you know zero to 1280 and then zero
to 720 to being like zero to 1920
because we've actually expanded that
area and the fact that OpenGL doesn't
know that is really the cause of why
these pixels are getting cut off because
as far as its concerned you know if we
flip back to the example that we have
here as far as its concerned that
initial rendering area that we created
our application with that is what it has
kind of data right so this kind of
rendering area where you can see
everything kind of renders correctly
which is when we created our winter with
the size of 1280 by 720 when we resize
that winter it still thinks that is
going from zero which is the bottom left
corner to 1280 by 720 right however you
can see there's much more space we just
haven't communicated that to OpenGL so
we need to do that the other
consideration doesn't affect us just yet
but in the future we won't be rendering
straight away to the screen or we won't
be basically rendering it into just into
OpenGL and
without actually creating our own frame
buffers in the future we'll actually set
up our own frame buffers and because we
set up our own frame buffers they also
need to get notified that the kind of
size of our window or the size of our
rendering area has changed because we'll
have to actually resize those textures
resize those frame buffers I'm not
really sure if it's worth considering
that the hazel development branch which
by the way is available to patrons
patron icon full-size that sure knows
the best way to support this series and
everything that I do here on YouTube the
hazel demand branch already handles all
of that stuff because we're not
rendering like that's got like a full
HDR pipe
so we're actually rendering true like a
floating-point buffer floating point
texture and then that is eventually
being rented again as a caught onto the
screen so because of that if there is a
window resize and also mention like
hazel Deb has like a full count like
viewer and like editor application and
so because of that we don't worry we're
actually rendering to the screen we're
entering too we have to rent it to a
texture anyway because that texture then
gets rendered into a panel because it's
like a full kind of double layer setup
in that application so because of that
it's a little bit more complicated
because you know even if you do like you
know resize other panels and make the
viewport smaller it has to be able to
handle that so ultimately my point is
that we need resizing to work and we
need it to work across probably frame
buffers in the future or definitely
frame buffers in the future because if
we just kind of limit it to our window
that's not gonna be good enough so the
the way that this like typically works
is that because the other thing with
frame buffers that you have to consider
is that frame buffers are not all the
size of your window if you're rendering
like a final kind of destination Buffett
yeah or like even an intermediate scene
buffer a lot of these buffers are
probably gonna be like a one to one kind
of ratio between your available
rendering area and you know what you're
actually setting your frame buffer to be
that's totally reasonable however think
about like I don't know if your
rendering like an intermediate buffer or
some kind of shadow map or anything like
that where you know maybe like a a
certain like render pass for blurring or
whatever you don't need that to be full
resolution you don't want to tie that to
the screen width and high it still might
be useful to know if the window has been
resized because for example if you're
keeping one of these buffers exactly 50%
over the resolution of your kind of full
frame kind of buffer then you do need to
still know if the windows change right
it might not necessarily be a fixed 1024
by 1024 buffer it might be like a kind
of a percentage or some kind of just
like some kind of ratio we'll say from
the actual available rendering area that
is our window so because of that you
still need to be notified about resizing
but it just might not be about resizing
that frame
for to be the exact width and height of
your available screen rendering area so
there's all of these complicated things
that you need that you need to think
about the door that might not might not
occur to you immediately if you haven't
like built kind of an engine before you
don't even need to have built much of an
engine like to run into these problems
because if as soon as you kind of think
about the fact that you're not rendering
to the full screen you're entering to a
frame buffer this Keio resizing stuff
will begin to affect you anyway but my
point more so is that the two stages are
telling OpenGL that our rendering area
has changed and then notifying all of
our frame buffers that there's been a
change in the actual screen resolution
and then we can kind of either resize
the buffer or do something like that now
that second part I don't think we're
gonna worry about too much today well
still set it up in a way that it will
work usually what you would have is
something called like a frame buffer
pool which is just like a all of your
frame buffers going to this kind of
central storage kind of collection that
way you can recycle them as well if you
need to but ultimately because of that
the application will will be it will
know about all frame buffers that you
actually have and therefore it can kind
of iterate over them and tell them
there's been a window resize and then
based on what type of frame buffer that
is for example if it's like a render
buffer that fills the screen in that
case it can resize its textures and
recreate itself basically which is what
its gonna have to do but that isn't
necessary for example if you just have a
1024 by 1024 shadow map or something
like that that you don't really care
about resizing based on the resolution
because yeah in like in 3d applications
that might not be necessary for all
things the other thing that I kind of
forgot to mention but I'm gonna mention
now is the camera so this again depends
on what you're going for
because we have an orthographic camera
here now what happens if we resize the
window we have two options we either
make everything bigger right so the the
squares that used to be 100 by 100
effective pixels on our screen might not
be 150 by 150 effective pixels on a
screen and why because everything's
increased they're just going to be
physically bigger because we've made the
window bigger or do we want more stuff
to fit onto the screen right so because
we've got you know this much more
available area on our
on our monitor maybe we want just to fit
more of these squares onto the screen
because we're basically kind of taking a
step back we're just expanding the area
in which we're kind of looking at which
basically means that if we resize the
window we're cropping it we're not
scaling it down with cropping yet so
that's another consideration that's
totally up to you depends totally
depends on the game that you're trying
to make the problem with that can be if
someone resizes they were introduced to
small if they've got a low low
resolution device or something like that
and they will just they might not be
able to play a game because everything's
nothing's gonna fit onto the screen I
mean like UI and stuff you probably
anchor to like you know right side of
the screen top side whatever and that
way when you resize and you do all of
that stuff it's gonna work fine however
with you know with the actual game and
all of the rendering to do with the game
that might not be resized correctly
right you might you might end up making
that no you might end up making your
camera view so kind of small right
because you've cropped it in so much
that you just won't be able to play the
game in that case it might be better to
kind of actually squeeze everything else
and make everything smaller so again up
to you but that's definitely something
you need to consider this isn't really
consideration for 3d cameras in that
case you pretty much always just make
you know you you end up making
everything smaller because that's just
you know a like a perspective projection
is just gonna work that way but with an
orthographic projection you know the way
that we zoom in and out as you know is
just by setting our boundaries so in
that case in my experience in our
orthographic cameras usually lend
themselves pretty well to just being
like I'm gonna fit more into the screen
now because my screens bigger so lots of
stuff to think about let's get this
initial work done which is going to be
to expand the rendering area so that we
can actually see everything fill up our
entire window so if we open the windows
window klass which contains all of our
events that actually come in this is how
we know about our resize right so if we
look at
the jail the jail table callback for we
have a set window size callback this
window resize event gets triggered every
time our window actually changes size
right and we can test that really easily
by just simply writing in a little label
say age set or I'll do a warning just so
much I love yellow and then we'll
basically just write in our window sighs
sir zero comma one and then we'll say
width height all right so just by using
something like this we can just check
that's kind of coming in right okay and
then let's just bring up that console so
we have nothing at the moment but if I
start changing the size here you can see
that dynamically as I'm actually still
changing it all those events coming in
is telling me the size of my window in
pixels so that's really good because
that's kind of what we need to use to
actually make everything else work so
this is triggered as an event which
means that it does actually get cold and
it does actually get propagated down our
event stack which basically means that
everything that the subscribes to events
should receive this unless something
blocks it so for us what we need to
think about is where this actually gets
triggered now where we handle this is
most likely going to be in the
application class and that of course is
platform independent and this is what
actually dispatches all of our events
down our layer stacks in the same way
that we kind of hook into this on window
closed event we also need to hook into
on window resize and this will be a
window resize event I'm just going to
use the event dispatcher of course here
like we did before resize event and then
if we pop over to the header file we
will add a on window resize and just
will just video window resize event ok
cool so now we've got that event if we
find the on window close event I'm just
gonna copy it and make the same thing
for our window resize so on window
resize just implementing that function
here
window resize event we all definitely
return false because we don't want
anything else to block this as in which
we want all the layers that are
subscribed to to this kind of event to
actually know about the event because it
might be important for them and then we
need to think about what we actually do
here so there's a few considerations
that I want to kind of talk about to do
with window resizing first of all what
happens if the window is minimized so
typically what will happen is the width
and height will be resized to 0 because
our window isn't actually taking up any
space on our screen it's been minimized
right so what I can actually do is test
out I'll just open up the application
just by hitting f5 and then what I'm
gonna do is hit a breakpoint on this
once we know that it hasn't received any
events at the beginning and then I'm
just going to hit minimize and see what
we actually get coming into this on
window resize event
okay so hazel is now running I'm just
gonna hit a break I'm just gonna set a
breakpoint on to return false and then
I'm just gonna minimize okay so you can
see that this breakpoint gets hit and if
we look at e see what our values
actually are you can see the width and
height are both set to zero so this
happens when the window gets minimized
now there's a problem with our current
the way the things work on windows and
minimize we can't see our application
however if we look at run and we take a
look at this for example this is all
still running all right so all of our
layers are being updated everything's
being still rendered even though our our
window is minimized so that's a little
bit silly we don't wanna be doing that
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
basically credible if statement here
that says if you don't get with equals 0
or get high equals zero I mean they
should both be 0 but it doesn't really
matter if either at the Missouri we
don't want to render anything it's got
nothing to render to will return false
so we won't do anything else in this
function but then I'll also set
something called minimized to true and
this is just going to be a bullying that
we have over here so the same way that
we have running I'll also make a little
and I'll actually make
a separate line minimized equals false
right and what's going to happen is that
if our window is minimized and then
obviously if we get past that and
minimize should be set to false because
we won't be minimized but um if we if we
get past this or rather if we set
minimized to true here in our run loop
what we want to do we can still measure
like you know last frame time or
whatever but basically that we don't
want to do is do any kind of layer after
updating now I am go away is something
different and we might still want to do
I'm GUI rendering because you'll notice
that if we minimize our main window I'm
going might be docked out and it might
be doing its own stuff so because of
that you know we might still want to be
doing that but layers definitely
shouldn't be updated so if not minimized
we're going to actually update our layer
stack and again yeah we could definitely
like minimize we could definitely deal
with this as well and just put that in
there and in fact if we were to be like
really pedantic we definitely don't need
to be solving buffers if the windows
minimize we can still pull events
obviously we'll need to do that actually
but the swap buffers doesn't really need
to be triggered at all but we're not
gonna worry too much about that for now
that should be fine and if I do run it
like this then you'll see that if I
minimize this then we should not be
running this anymore and you can see
this I'm going window becomes
unresponsive that's because of that
that's why I didn't want to put it in
there so let's take a look at this one
more time and we'll take it out and do
it the way that I want to do it I just
wanted to demonstrate why that was
important because this is kind of our
main rendering area this is not dealing
with any I'm GUI windows which by the
way you would not have it in a
distribution kind of version of this
project right so if you actually ship
your game using hazel you're not gonna
have any iron GUI layer stuff so this is
just for like the editor kind of
application or any kind of tools that it
supplies so if we minimize this now you
can see this is still kind of responsive
because still doing all that stuff but
what's not happening is this is
minimized so none of our layers you can
see we skip past that because minimize
is true none of our layers are being
updated which is really good because
that's where we'll be doing all of the
kind of intensive drawings so if we're
men
our application you won't be using all
of our CPU time for our computer or our
GP you're trying to render everything
even though it doesn't nature so that's
one thing that we should do upon window
resize anyway now that we've done that
you know we obviously know that yet with
and get high and in fact if we look at
windows window and we look at this again
you can see that we actually I don't
think this is the case but I'm Donna ok
I'm Donna with an M Donna hi ok good
so our width and height are actually
changed for our window which is good so
if we query the window at any point and
we ask it what the width the height is
then it will just it'll know right
because it'll you know look at this and
well it'll it will actually update our
data which is important because we
obviously want that new with the new
height to be in our current width and
current height for our window
now the next step here is going to be
basically just telling the application
that it's changed so for this again what
we would usually do is basically look at
the frame buffer pool or at least tell
the renderer in some way or another
a renderer and if we look at I don't
know how we do this here so we have a
renderer in it and then what do we do we
basically just propagate layers okay
cool
we're basically need to tell the
renderer that that the frame buffer is
kind of resized if we take a look at our
render API to do this now we have in it
begins in and saying all that stuff cool
what will actually do is this is all
fully static at the moment which is fine
what I'll do is I will add something
called on window resize which is just
going to be an event this will take an
we'll just say width and height it's
really all we need we'll keep it simple
I'll go ahead and implement that and
then what this is going to do is just
issue a render command which is gonna be
full step viewport and this is gonna set
the viewport from 0 0 to width and
height so again this this is some code
that you may have to change if you're
entering multiple viewports because upon
wind
you don't want to immediately
immediately set the viewport to do this
this will need to be reworked based on
frame buffers that are added in the
future but this is just the simplest way
to get this up and running right now so
that's why I'm writing code like this I
just wanna stress and I'm gonna do that
enough but I just want to stress that in
this series I will I'll put this here
actually in this series I will very
often write code that is somewhat
temporary because it has to work with
our current code base there's no way I
can kind of write this complete engine
from scratch and just have everything
perfect from the beginning because
that's just not gonna work at all so
just keep in mind that the stuff that
may change will add that interaction as
we always do so step viewport and then X
Y width height and then I'll go to our
render API and then I'll create that
stuff set viewport
I'll just copy all of these documents
here and paste them into here and then a
last step is the OpenGL render API we're
going to just stick that in okay so
seven people X Y width height and then
if we go into here let me just copy you
like a bit of this and then I'll just
replace it with that okay and then what
this is gonna do is call GL viewport X Y
width height just like we wanted to all
right that's the underlying OpenGL
command that we call and now if we go
over to let's see so our renderer should
do that on the resize
it looks like it does which is good if
we go to application we just do renderer
on window resize and we just do a job
get with get high and if we hit f5 then
we should have everything working
basically it should now render to the
entire screen area and not just the 1280
by 720 viewport that we originally had
so if I maximize this you can see it now
fills the screen all right and then if I
like make the smaller you can see that
should still kind of you know keep the
camera in mind so you can see the ratio
is staying the same here but you know if
we make it bigger or smaller or whatever
you can see that everything is rendered
because it now is aware of our actual
render render size which is good now the
next step which is optional because that
might be exactly what you're going for
right but the next step which is
optional might be to actually make
everything smaller or bigger because you
can see what's happening now is no
matter what size were actually at
everything's gonna stay the same size
see so this channel logo takes up you
know a percentage of this kind of screen
width and height and then no matter how
big I make this if I maximize it it
still kind of is the same right
everything just gets scaled up or down
depending on how much rendering area
we're working with now what you might
want to do instead is actually show more
or less based on that right so don't
change the size of the scene just change
basically the viewport into the scene so
to do that we need to change our camera
projection matrix so what we can do is
again over here in on event we're gonna
hook into I'll just do this here I don't
think I'll actually keep this but I kind
of like the way the things are or maybe
I will we'll see what it looks like so
what I'll do is I'll just do let's see
if e dot get event type equals event
time so I haven't done anything this way
in a while but I just don't want to
write a dispatcher right now what we'll
do is a window as well then v window
resize of it if it's a window resize
event
which is cost into that so hazel window
resize events II and will actually say
to that
resize event alright so get with and get
hi is what we're dealing with now so to
do something like this though what you
actually need to do is think about what
the projection matrix originally is
right so what we actually set it to and
this is why I probably wouldn't
recommend you do this but well we
actually set it to is an aspect ratio
multiplied by our zoom level right so
effectively what should happen is the
zoom should go in and out that's kind of
what we're talking about here if the if
the orthographic camera was simply set
to be the size of your window meaning
that instead of this kind of aspect
ratio zoom level stuff where where it
could be potentially like you know -16
de positive 16 or something like that in
if instead of that you just had 0 to
1280 and 0 to 720 as your actual
orthographic camera projection matrix if
that was the case then you just simply
change it to be the size of the window
now and that's usually how you I will
probably be done you probably do that in
kind of like a pixel basis you wouldn't
do it like this which is kind of what
you might render your game world in but
since we don't have that we effectively
just need to set the zoom level so that
should not be too difficult a zoom level
starts at 1 which is our main kind of so
at 1280 by 720 one is kind of what we're
dealing with what we just need to do is
basically have a little set zoom level
so we'll basically have a level and I'll
just set zoom level to be whatever level
is okay
so then what this will do and I guess
I'll add a guest zoom level as well so
just
turn zoom level I put together first as
I always drew so now what we should be
able to do is basically just set our
camera zoom zoom level so camera
controller dot says zoom level and what
this will have to be the function based
on the width and height and what it's
changed to now this is difficult because
we do basically need to pick one right
because we can't do both right and
especially because our window doesn't
have to be the same aspect ratio as it
was before but what we can do is say
that the width which is this thing so
we'll say let's just take a float
zoomed so the width we know is whatever
our window width is now at 1280 if the
width is 1280 that is a new level of 1
right so it's pretty easy for us to say
well in that case and this will be
complicated by the fact that you know we
have to flip this light up but doesn't
matter if we divide our width which H
customers foot probably and this is re
if we divide our width by 1280 we get a
zoom level of 1 right and then what we
actually want to do is flip that so that
if we kind of make it smaller or bigger
because the thing is at this particular
point if we actually make the window
smaller it will zoom in more and we can
test that out actually by just putting
this into here well test this out by
just resizing the window right so if I
make this small like is who we actually
zoom in where as what we probably wanted
to do was kind of zoom out in a way but
hang on a minute
we're already doing that actually I just
totally forgot about this so yeah so in
other words what we probably should be
doing is touching our zoom level which
you can see that that doesn't even get
affected here ok so this is a lot more
complicated than I thought
some completely backpedal on most of
this because the thing is I'll zoom
level especially when we set the zoom
level doesn't recalculate our projection
like at all so not to mention the fact
that I think yeah so camera control on
events happening here and then the zoom
levels being affected so this setting
the zoom level isn't enough we actually
have to reset the projection
completely so that's not gonna work at
all
we actually get rid of this stuff and
here f-five then what we should find is
that if we resize in one axis this
actually should work already it's only
if we resize in both the X and y axis
that everything should get bigger
because the aspect ratio doesn't really
change neither does the zoom level sorry
if I actually just expand this right you
can see that more stuff will fit onto
the screen right which is kind of what
we want it's only when we resize it in
both axes that our that does it actually
end up making everything smaller and to
stop that what you would actually need
to do is just expand both of the
boundaries that's kind of what zoom is
for to expand and to kind of zoom in and
out and it does that by just shifting
the boundaries around but with the
design of this alter graphic camera
controllers Pro it's probably no point
in doing that because it's gonna knock
off a zoom level completely and it's not
gonna make that stuff happen so in other
words this is actually a really good
hybrid approach which I didn't even
realize that I'd done because we did
actually do that stuff you can see if
you had like an ultra wide monitor or
something then more would fill in screen
right so if I move this like left or
right like this and zoom in and out or
whatever you can see that I can actually
physically fit more onto my screen then
for example if I was like on a portrait
of fern where I can't actually fit more
than just that so that's kind of cool
however it means that we can do that and
the same thing would kind of work
vertically right so if I was kind of
like this but then I was able to
introduce more vertical room just like
that then you can see that it actually
does make everything smaller or bigger
because that aspect ratio is kind of
dependent on one axis which is the width
so in a way that's pretty much exactly
what I want us to achieve you could play
around with this a little bit more to
customize it to your liking if you are
considering doing something like this
which might be useful for like you are
entering the projection matrix you would
choose would be one that kind of matches
your pixel count anyway so in other
words instead of dealing with like an
arbitrary kind of boundary boundaries
which is what we're doing right now
which is kind of setting into
aspect-ratio time zoom what you would do
instead is actually have like from 0 to
12 any as I mentioned before is 0 to 720
which is your actual pixel count and in
that in that sense it would make sense
to actually resize it because then you
could just make it you could just make
the new width and high it still sub from
0 but the new width and height would be
however however many pixels you actually
have available to you so anyway that's
pretty much how resizing works and how I
would handle it again in the future when
we do introduce frame buffers is gonna
be really important to actually
propagate these these resize changes to
those frame buffers so that they are
aware that the screen has actually
changed because we weren't rendering to
the screen in the future but I hope you
guys enjoy this video if you did please
hit that like button you can also help
support a series by going to a journal
collection channel as I mentioned
earlier a lot of stuff that I've talked
about in this episode has already been
done there and not to mention I'm
actually I'm actually sort of working on
the 2d renderer for hazel in that
development branch so if you want to
check out the 2d renderer and batching
and all of this kind of stuff that is
actually I guess working now then check
that out I don't think I've pushed that
yet because I'm also just wrapping up a
commit which which introduces
multi-threading into hazel dev so
basically we have our entire rendering
stuff running on a separate render
thread so that's stuff I think I'm
haven't really pushed yet so as soon as
that push is done the 2d rendering will
also be done so exciting stuff there
definitely check it out and I will see
you guys next time good bye
[Music]